tenemos una función aquí definida por
una serie infinita lo que quiero hacer
es ver si lo podemos expresar en una
forma más tradicional lo que te puede
saltar a la vista es que si fuera una
serie geométrica ya ya sabemos
calcularla en el intervalo de
convergencia así que vamos a ver si esto
de aquí en verdad es una serie
geométrica ok entonces si nosotros
quisiéramos ver eso tendríamos que ver
que cada cada sumando se puede obtener
de la anterior multiplicando por el
mismo factor vamos a ver para llegar de
2 a menos 8 x cuadrada necesitamos
multiplicar por menos 4 x cuadrada muy
bien qué pasa si queremos llegar de
menos 8 x cuadrada a 32 x cuarta bueno
para anular el signo tenemos que
multiplicar por menos 8 por 4 nos da 32
entonces vamos bien y x cuadradas
necesitamos multiplicar la x x cuadrada
para obtener x 4 entonces vemos que este
mismo factor funciona para obtener este
tercer sumando igual para calcular este
para bueno si multiplicamos por menos 4x
cuadrada tendremos menos 4 por 32 son
128 y x cuarta por x cuadrada es x sexta
entonces esta serie en efecto es una
serie geométrica ok con nuestra
proporción común igual a menos 4 x
cuadrada entonces fx la podemos expresar
como una serie la serie donde sumamos
desde n igual a 0 hasta a infinito de 2
x menos 4 x cuadrada y esto elevado a la
n muy bien entonces esta serie tiene
como proporción común a menos 4 x
cuadrada y ahora la pregunta es cuando
convergen y lo que sabemos es que esta
serie converge esta serie converge
la proporción común que es menos 4x
cuadrada y tomamos su valor absoluto es
menor que 1 ok pero bueno sabemos que el
valor absoluto de un número es igual a
menos o es igual perdón al valor
absoluto de menos ese número entonces
esto es lo mismo que el valor absoluto
de 4x cuadrada y esto debe ser menor que
1 muy bien entonces también notemos que
x cuadrada es un número no negativo y 4
es un número positivo así que al
multiplicarlo este número es no negativo
y por lo tanto coincide con su valor
absoluto así que esto nos da 4x cuadrada
debe ser menor que 1 o lo que es lo
mismo
x cuadrada debe ser menor que un cuarto
ok
y ahora para obtener ya la las x que
funcionan sacamos raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados y obtenemos que el valor absoluto
de x debe ser menor que la raíz cuadrada
de un cuarto y eso es
ok o lo que es lo mismo que menos un
medio es menor que equis y esto es menor
que un medio así que esto de aquí es
nuestro intervalo de convergencia y este
de aquí lo podemos ver de la siguiente
forma que x debe a la distancia de x al
0 es menor que un medio así que el radio
de convergencia en este caso es un medio
así que estos casos cuando cuando x se
encuentra en este intervalo intervalo
perdón de convergencia o cuando x dista
del 0 - que el radio de convergencia que
es un medio aquí es cuando esta serie
geométrica converge pero ya sabemos
también calcular cuál es el valor al que
convergen verdad y esto es
el primer término que en este caso es 2
dividido entre 1 - la proporción común
que es menos 4x cuadrada así que
finalmente y ya nos merecemos un redoble
de tambor porque esto es 2 entre 1 + 4x
cuadrada ok así que las expresiones son
iguales esta serie geométrica es igual a
esta función y que la función está
definida de esta forma así que las
expresiones son iguales siempre que x se
encuentre en el intervalo de
convergencia